optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking and I also do personal
question now let's see
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton dozens maybe
even hundreds of you have asked me what
shirts are you wearing on YouTube videos
for very specific set of shirts and they
are from Rowan apparel rh o n e and i'm
packing for a trip for seven to ten days
and i'd say half of what i'm going to
pack is from run these are the most
comfortable shirts and they have much
more than shirts that i have ever worn
at least for active wear for getting out
and about and you can even sneak them in
to say a business casual or a dinner if
you want if you're a Long Island kid
like me they have minimal branding you
don't feel like you are walking around
with some type of billboard on your
chest anti-odor technology because I am
a smelly bastard and I can somewhat end
up smelling like a musk ox half way
through the day
they've pure melted down silver in their
fabrics and I love these shirts I love
their pants I love the shorts and I've
been wearing them pretty much every day
for the last few weeks at least one item
from them so you should check it out
this stuff is not cheap because it is
made from premium materials and if you
want the best you got to pay for the
best and that's just the way it is but
there's no risk in trying them out they
provide free shipping and a 100 day
return policy that is plenty of time to
feel them out so check it out at Roane
dot-com forward slash Tim that's our h o
n e com forward slash Tim you can get
15% off which is exclusive for listeners
of this podcast you're welcome using the
code Tim you got to use the code folks
and at that URL rom-com forward slash
Tim you will also see the shirt that I
would suggest maybe starting with it is
the Scout crew neck shirt I like the red
I like the black I'm wearing the red
right now as I record this and that is
all for this sponsor announcement so
check it out Ron comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by trunk
club there are two types of men out
there you know who you are guys who love
shopping for clothes but are short on
time
category a and those of you who hate it
category B I am in the latter category
my fashion sense is also probably
somewhere between homeless and confused
with a dash of lazy added in either way
you can take heart and I've used trunk
club now and have found some of my
favorite pieces of clothing that make me
look a lot better than I'll be able to
handle on my own and there are many
reasons for that but you can get
clothing that fits perfectly and looks
amazing without ever stepping into a
store again thanks to trunk club and
they make it very very easy and the
clothing is handpicked by a personal
stylist your own personal stylist all
you have to do is go to trunk club comm
forward slash Tim type in your
measurements share your likes and
dislikes they'll pick your clothes from
more than 80 top brands and ship them
right to your door you keep what you
like you send back what you don't if you
don't like any of it send it all back
doesn't matter
and trunk club is not a subscription
service this is what appealed to me
among many other things I didn't want to
constantly be getting dinged by things
or have to deal with the headache of
constantly getting boxes it's not a
subscription service shipping is always
free and you have five days to try on
the clothes so a couple points here
number one get started today go to trunk
club comm forward slash Tim try it out
you get premium clothes expert advice no
work no risk that is a winning combo and
I have found some of my favorite
espadrilles shoes from them bright green
I do like the color green and they
actually work I've had so many
compliments on these shoes and more
people ask me where I got them than any
other pair of shoes I've ever had and
more shirts I kept ended up keeping
about I would say 3/4 of my box which I
did not expect to do so go to trunk club
comm forward slash Tim and check it out
this is Tim Paris and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job to deconstruct world-class
performers to tease out the habits tools
beliefs tricks and so on that you can
apply to your life in this episode we
have one of your favorites we have
Charles Poliquin back for another round
and in this episode he is answering your
favorite questions those questions that
were uploaded the most by you guys
Charles you can find him on Twitter and
elsewhere at strength essence' and
strength since I comm is one of the
best-known strength coaches in the world
he has trained elite athletes from 20
plus sports including Olympic gold
medalist NFL all pros NHL all-stars
Stanley Cup champions IFBB bodybuilding
champs his client list is long it
includes long jump gold medalist Wade
Phillips NHL MVP Chris Pronger
and the MLB batting champion Edgar
Martinez among many others end the lady
who won the first gold in Olympic
wrestling for the US so the list
continues to grow and as we creep
towards episode number 200 what how did
that happen
his first appearance on the podcast is
still one of the top 15 most listened to
episode so you should definitely check
that out it is controversial and very
very fun and very very dense and he is
constantly requested by you guys for
around two so here you have it in this
episode we cover a lot he goes deep on
several topics including his favorite
mass building program of all time
recommendations for older lifters latest
thoughts on hormones insulin of course
insulin is a subset of hormones and diet
how to differentiate Oh can't handle the
syllables today how to differentiate a
terrible trainer from a good one and the
good from the best of the best his
nighttime routine for improved improving
sleep oh my goodness gracious I need
more sleep why most people screw up
abdominal training ketosis and modeled
muscle gain and much much more so I'm
gonna go drink more coffee and I hope
you enjoy round 2 with Charles
Poliquin
hi welcome to the tim ferriss show our
first question from Kevin James he's
asking for recommendations for older
letters 40 plus but with a lot of years
of experience he's asking what's the
Seth what's the Raps what's best for
this and he also points out there's not
very much advice for experienced lifters
and he's also saying wondering is it all
downhill from here well let's look at it
this way all systems in your body human
body will age your hair gets gray your
eyesight drops your hearing drops over a
year so everything drops and your muscle
strength and muscle mass will also drop
but what's a acceptable rate or drop
best way to measure that is actually
we'll look at the world Masters
Championships and weightlifting and what
you typically see is that the world
record holders and/or youth when they
competed in seniors or the Olympic Games
or world Senior Championships whatever
they can do let's say IH 34 Beatles
about one percent one percentage point
per year so let's say if the guy did 200
kilos at his best at the Olympics in the
snatch 20 years later
he'll do about 160 kilos and I thought
see the guys kept on training really
hard so some people advanced the fact it
could be 1 percent per year after the
age of 26 but a lot of it has to do with
training methodology so you have to have
realistic goals of what's good for your
age group the best place to find that
information is actually Brookes cubic as
a book series a book called dinosaur
training secrets in volume 2 which is
called off strong ru which you can find
on Amazon the outlines lift specific
norms and age specific norms so let's
say you're 60 years old and you want to
know what's a good back squat on your 60
go there in through age and let the
lifts and you'll be able to see what's
good for you I think having realistic
goals
will appease your mind you're not going
to do it 70 what you did when he
completed the Olympics obviously so
that's what I would do for you but you
will as far as training recommendations
as far as sets and reps because of
declining hormone levels you're be able
to recover from workouts is somewhat
impaired if you are on a hormone
replacement therapy and yet
testosterone therapy gh therapy thyroid
therapy and so on you will lose some but
not as fast as one of your colleagues is
not AB they're all moans replaced the
next question is from yasser Nadeem he
stipulates you said that one must sleep
be lean and after and carbs 10% less
aachen one tester individuals and sent
insulin sensitivity and determine if
they are lean enough to make good use of
carbs or not well the point is is that
if you're fat you don't need to do any
blood work to find out that you need
carbs so for a male your body fat should
be less than ten percent less than ten
percent we mean that when you stand up
we can see your abdominals and you can
see the Linea Alba therefore we could
see every row of ABS most people think
of it they have abs if you can see one
that's not abs you could do blood work
the best blood marker to see if you
deserve your carbohydrates is actually
the HP one you see you could run that
test for fourteen to forty dollars it's
always covered by insurance there's many
more sophisticated tests for this one
we'd be good enough and you want to have
your HP one in Cibolo 4.8 if it is below
for pretty sure can afford carbohydrates
now you may want to eat carbs when you
26% but don't complain you your body
position is not improving if I put you
on a desert island and now I give you is
protein and fat and fiber being if you
want a carb
you're not going to die there's no such
thing as an essential carbohydrate so I
think for most people just sheer
laziness that makes them Birds on carbs
you if you don't deserve them and you
want to get lean then you got to stay
away until you get lean but it shouldn't
take you that long question number three
comes from Jim Mulhern yes what's your
best routine for mass and confusable
best way to spend time between strength
word sets which feels like it adds up a
lot of wasted time if I get this
question every day Tim asked me to talk
about it we've seen at least 10 times
Tim's Facebook page about 25 times when
people ask me what I questions and the
last time I posted on that what I've
done it for the team first listeners is
that I've looked back at what I've done
in the last 38 years and found the best
approach for that so in this it's a book
it's an e-book and I am going over
everything with all the types of splits
you do because not everybody can commit
the most time to it I mean they
obviously the fastest way to gain mass
is to spend a lot of time right but it's
only good to a certain point we have
what we call the law of diminishing
returns so I did tell you which exercise
to do the what type of supplement and
I've actually filmed every exercise so
there's no guessing left taking pictures
and the hxi is actually filmed from two
different angles so should be very clear
for you to get that I've never ever sold
my programs like that online so I'm
going to be get available on my site for
two weeks
and then take it down if you're
interested check it out it includes 12
weeks of routines Auto personalize your
workouts and you should advice
everything you need to get the book go
to strengths and sitcom slash mass so to
answer your question in a nutshell your
muscles will grow faster if you spend
usually two or three weeks working on
training volume usually your reps will
be higher than eighth up you could you
have as much as 50 for the quadriceps
and then you go two to three weeks on
low reps because after a while the
amount of weight you can actually use
for high reps
is what dictates how much muscle mass
you're going to gain so if you week four
reps it's going to limit Austria and
massive you'll get so from experience I
mean I've had a lot of a sport where
people need to increase muscle mass
whether it's rugby or hockey or American
football and I found over the last 38
years that the alternation of volume
versus which we call it accumulation
phases vs. intense nation faces is
probably the most productive way to gain
mass and if you go to my website
strength sitcom I got all sorts of
examples of mass building routines next
question comes feather bear and please I
apologize if I don't have the right
pronunciation I only speak three
languages so I don't always know it's
pronounced he says in the last podcast
you mentioned got Chico doing good job
again stretch mark what dosage do you
use usually if it's a good standardized
extract like the one made by Gaia GA I a
you would take six capsules of 500
milligrams and divide the dosage so two
tablets three times a day and it works
wonders the next question is from Bryce
Lee what injuries did you personally
have to deal with the career of
maximizing swole or trophy and how do
you deal with them it seems that no
matter how careful we are we named it
oblique run into injuries if we pursue
atrophy and PRS for their own sake of
age the best way to avoid injury is
actually rotation in the exercises my
friend Matt Benning was two old records
in the squat has had zero injuries but
if you look at his methodology he has a
lot of variation he doesn't overuse
exercises so if you healed up my website
strength is calm I actually talked about
overuse injuries the biggest cause of
injury is to stick to favorite exercise
and nauseam I just did a tour with Matt
and Ed cones on multiple time world
champion province he set over 72 World
Records he's had a few injuries compared
to Matt and at lunch she was discussing
that if you were to start his life over
you would have varied is exercise
selection more often because it's like
anything else if you don't change the
pattern overload of the given exercise
your cartilage is always exposed to the
same amount of stress proper warm-up
ethic is the most essential way to
prevent injuries avoiding static
stretching before lifting prevents
injuries getting erect regular soft
tissue work prevent injuries but one
thing that dr. Robert Rakowski points
out is that we live in a more and more
polluted air and II find and all my
lifting coaches colleagues over the age
of 50 is people are getting injured more
often and more severe than before and
one of the things that the Robert
Bartowski points out is toxic overload
pesticides heavy metals and so on so if
you pay attention to eliminate all sorts
of toxins and do things like chelation
therapy you diminish your toxic load
which we should help you prevent
injuries so there's a vacuum Institute
but there's also the biomechanics of it
the question is from Jason Bartlett he
says like YouTube fitness experts or
so-called experts unrealistic workouts
and expectations set by hand hands
people that kind of sets up for
unrealistic expectation and goals says
how do we combat misinformation I agree
with you there's a lot of people on the
internet have no place being there but
there's no such thing as a board to look
at the quality of what's up YouTube
however I think what you have to look
more to is that as the person add
results of themselves and are they good
at training other people so if I want to
have an intelligent discussion
with strength training experts I know
we're fine because they've produced
athletes multiple times in repetitive
fashion so for example Josh Bryant has
very good books on weight training and
the information he publishes actually
works is the lightest mantle at
benchpress 600 pounds
guys like Paula Carter can give you good
information at Combe but to go in the
air net for reliable sources of
information can be rather confusing what
I think is a shortcut to do that is to
take seminars with those guys this is a
lot of stuff you can't put in a book or
that for example with technique in a
squat or the deadlift you can't learn
that through a book or by watching
videos what do you think you're doing
and what you're actually doing are two
different things so what I would do if I
were you instead of wasting your time
and the internet watching stupid stuff
that doesn't do anything I would look at
those guys and hire them for consult
because another thing if you're too
cheap for to pay for information you'll
fall by the wayside and most of this
stuff that is there for free is actually
worth noting because a lot of people are
trying to make a place under the Sun and
they'll stay stupid stupid stuff just to
be different but it doesn't mean that's
any good like Tim says you know you
could put your the where over your pants
but is it more is it better or is it
more fun it's a more fun for people to
laugh at you but it's certainly not more
comfortable or better so different and
and better are not synonyms and it's
better to use someone who's had time
tried training methods then is a
peer-reviewed peer-reviewed crowd never
produced anybody and only wait till it's
published in science with 60 papers I
went trust those guys either because
they don't have any clinical experience
CIBC consulting a virgin sex therapist
the next question is Marco creati asks
what differentiates between a good
personal trainer for a great TT where
should someone start if they want to
become a PT or accountant mistakes PT
make what officials the biggest sure the
PT I have to start teaching strength
what an initial strength courses
shouldn't explain PT take thank you well
your ability to produce results is what
distinguishes you in the field for
example Ning Mitchell and also the
performance they establish your brand by
producing results so if you go to knee
you pee around the world whether it's an
RBS pain or if you're going to
Manchester UK there's a wall full of
success stories and those success
stories are always within about 12 weeks
so the best way to learn my opinion is
to offer to do free internship with a
well producing gym like shredded in
Australia or well gate in Prague so seek
out Wes constant good results and
opportunity under them for free because
you have no experience and then they
will teach you the system and they will
point you the right books when your
question is be very long to answer
but official certifications in my
opinion don't mean much I've seen people
with lots of different certifications
and it still your ability to produce
results that makes a difference and you
have to learn how to do a training
system so if you told me I want to be a
great strength coach I would say go
learn with band prentace in connecticut
these produce years over years of NHL
players and if l players major league
baseball players because you can't
acquire the stuff just in classes and
just buy books you have to get so much
what I would say in the trenches and
those guys that strongly recommended
people spend a fortune in education and
they will actually save you time so if
you go in turn let's say a month for
free at AUP provided they accept you
because it allows you to see you know
some colors before you show up you would
learn far more than taking thousands of
hours of certification courses in the
near future I will produce videos for
idea which is the largest certification
company in the world and those will be
good to get your theory down but if you
listen to those videos you'll have a
good idea of what reps you should do
sets so that you're prepared once you go
into the field to maximize your results
but what makes a great PT which is a
good PD is simply the ability to produce
results but you need to learn the
systems from a world-class mentor the
next comes from question comes from
Danielle matheus Casimir Chuck typical
Irish name which supplements do you
currently use for improving sleep
personally I'm a big fan of magnesium
three and eight I take six capsules at
bedtime mixed with two grams of theanine
th a and I any I will post a page to
where to get these ingredients on the
website the next question comes from
Marcus Beamer there are many things you
might regret but what's the thing that
comes to mind most often well why would
I change if I could do it again I wish
before our week would have been
published when I started my career
people tell me often you are very lucky
I got very lucky by working 20 hours a
day for years on end so when you worked
that many hours and that doesn't include
training so four years for about eight
months out of the year will only sleep
three hours a night that would say
that's my biggest mistake I said yes too
often and I should have been concerned
more with the quality of the athletes
that train the problem was is that when
I would get the IRA I would get the
whole National
once I establish your Billy being
consistent results when I would
negotiate with national team I would
tell national team these are the guys
I'll pick these are the guys that will
train so it would have saved me time on
writing programs and miss training
programs monitoring programs teaching
technique but you need to have a
reputation before so I spend a lot of
time doing that what I've learned over
the last few years is that you get no
better jobs you turn down not the jobs
you accept it months ago Ellen my rule
is when the gold in Olympic wrestling
for women first time in America did so
for weeks I've been asked to do seminars
write books take on more National Team
athletes train foreign teams and I said
no all one of these requests why because
every gear nut I don't do the 4-hour
workweek but I'd like to do the four and
half hour workday and you know one thing
I do regularly is I take a week off a
month to rest to read and I take three
months vacation a year probably having a
child which by the best thing for me you
learn other prioritize things so I
really start to cut back on the amount
of work once and my daughter but the
biggest mistake you've ever done was to
work far too much now guys a guy ran a
check will say hustle you do but you
should still favor
quality over quantity and if you want to
understand the concept better I strongly
suggest you read the one thing and three
to four hour work week it's just a
mental outlook to what you do the next
question is from Jonathan Anderson
thanks to Charles I'm not big into
omega-3s to keep my oh you mean
remission dr. Barry Sears says through
two one EPA to DHA I'm taking that ratio
at about a greater expanse is it worth
it should everyone go on well dr. genial
before she passed away a few years ago
was probably the smartest guys on that
topic what we know is that it's actually
better to vary the types if you're sure
as an axiom should respect is that the
more you're dealing with information the
Rd EP a ratio to DHA should be so a lot
of brands will sell you a 6 to 1 ratio
that will bring down the inflammation
better than the 3 to 1 ratio actually if
you're concerned with brain so it's if
you have a DD ADHD borderline
personality all the studies on brain
disorders show that a high DHA omega-3
product is better so usually you want to
8 DHA to EPA to 1 V P a ratio but
there's no magical official and they I
think we know not from research it's
better to take products like omega-3 a
veil from designs for health where it's
also mixed in at d1 a d3 sorry k1 and k2
into the product because those actually
increase absorption you don't need as
much large kuan-yin of course your
supplement is important fat soluble
vitamins the next question is from rod
Ely in the ass V you're not a big fan of
foam rolling isn't foam rolling a
massage thing it my beef against foam
rolling is that it will be trying to
build a bridge one pebble at the time it
takes far too long so this is a thing as
a principle of training economy I mean
Tim is big on that whether you for our
body or any of his broach it's like you
have to have maximum return least amount
of time so people waste tremendous
amount of time foam rolling the amount
of time the waste on foam rolling could
be trying to get flexible could be done
in a good 20 minute actively section or
roughing technique or the walleye method
there's a lot of stuff out there that
exists to get rid of adhesions and
improve range of motion so and let's see
if you have a good activity spec
Tichenor and your form rolling because
you have a tight shoulder if the guy
does ago
job and let's say you the worst case
scenario yes but as flexible as a
crowbar within five treatments you'll a
higher percent range of motion and if
you're complete certified idiot
you will still maintain those gains for
six weeks so that's six months I'm sorry
so in my opinion to go sick a very good
soft tissue practitioner and investor
took the time and money into that will
save you all these countless hours of
foam rolling because it will you will
have the results and it will be more
permanent if you see a soft tissue
therapist next question comes from clay
Steadman asking me you have a lifting
plan for body transformation even today
element sure a lot of people would like
to buy it well like I said I've done a
mass program and the thing with a mass
program is that people get so obsessed
with fat loss that they should actually
be focusing on mass and strength because
the increase your muscle mass you become
more insulin sensitive therefore fat
loss is accelerated so when people come
in and if you look at the research when
the fastest way to lose fat is actually
bodybuilding programs I mean they did a
study on Parikh an obese teenagers and
one group that won our cardio one group
is one hour of weight training and the
mid group did the half weight training
our cardio and turns out that the group
is it cardio got fatter and the group is
bit lifted weights for an hour got not
only leaner but also getting some muscle
mass and the group we did the
intermediate program at a mixture the
two extreme groups so in my opinion for
body composition is actually focusing
increasing muscle mass works far better
than trying to focus on fat loss the
next question is from the Lee are Perry
he says considering the magnitude of the
cell phone industry how do we know which
cell phones are more effective or at all
how do we know if they even work well
you could go on PubMed and Google a
supplement and then you'll find the
research that backs it up or tells you
it doesn't work a lot of times
southern companies made what I call
extended claims there's a good website
called gulag comm there's a subversion
com there's examined comm and those
websites will tell you the real deal of
course there's a strong commercial bias
do supplements work yes yes but one of
the major things that dictates the
quality supplement is outer mate so if
you buy a subtle in Canada which has
very strong regulatory laws on
supplement making you'll get a good
product because it's the trouble you can
get in if you produce a crap sulphur is
far too extensive and the government
that's all testing for you before you
get approved or that that's why one of
the reasons why I use ATP labs it's made
in Canada and because it's made in
Canada I know the quality is very high
for example Norway is very strong on
protecting your own supplement industry
but because of the high quality of
Canaan supplements you can actually ship
Kenyan supplement Kenyan maid
supplements into Norway and they pass
customs but it's not through for
Sullivans all over the world
UK is probably the country where they
make the worst supplements they do have
strong legislation but it's never been
applied and they estimate that if the UK
were to put that lot into action
80% of supplement companies in UK would
be closing their doors so depending
where you live you may have access to
high quality supplements or not if
you're going to buy supplements I
strongly recommend you buy them from a
health practitioner because elf practise
your branch far more severe self-imposed
restriction on quality control and when
trust most of the stuff you see on the
internet because of that next question
comes from Gabe Gabe Rivera this is one
squatting high bar or low bar yield
lifting shoes or flats trained with with
or without a belt a lot needs to Deford
ask to give back these topics are not
agreed upon University please explain
why the goal being maximal strength in
my piripi well Gabe this is the reality
all the forms
squats you talked about are good the
only thing I'm not big on is squatting
with a belt I think you should allow
your your core to develop at the same
rate as you develop your hip and knee
extensors because let's say if you like
to do slalom skiing if you always train
with a belt and you ski without a belt
your core muscles are not matching your
leg strength so you can get into trouble
if your wrestler you're not going to be
allowed to wear that belt when you go to
the mat so the trunk muscles should be
baller the same rate as as a hip
extensors on my website I got plenty of
different ways you could squat
I've actually filmed over on Ernie forms
a good squat so there's a lot of to
choose from and going back to what I
said earlier on by the ED cone he also
things that you should have there your
squats more often to stay injury-free
like Matt Benning the next question is
from Sam Sinclair
he says Charles heavyset Set guy 240
pound trying to reduce fat loves lifting
but training five days a week can't
shift it mostly paleo okay post 8:00
p.m. wine and crab foods the battle I
don't expect miracles for wooden tip
from a master
Namastey well Sam let me break it to you
all in you art comes from the choices
you make so if you 80% good and 20%
terrible well don't expect to have 1%
results what I would suggest you do if
there's one tip I give you is only take
on one Abbot per week so for example
chewing lean people to their foods 45
times fat people to their foods 15 times
so you could get on those counters that
bouncers use to control any people that
went to the bar and just do this start
on this Saturday because you won't have
any excuses chew your food and every
time you take a chook click the clicker
and see what happens and you will find
that you rush to Swan your faucet them
so the low cost tip for fat loss is
actually turning your food even if
you're trying to gain muscle mass it's
true to most people inhale their food
nothing you have to pay attention to so
it's a bonus tip is do you actually eat
in front of the screen are you on
Facebook while you are you answering
emails so mindful eating is another way
to lose fat and then most people were
not doing mindful eating and sit in
front of the screen consume far too many
calories this is a very good study from
France where they looked at female
college to is the first year and their
dietary intake versus eating mindfully
or officially eating in front of let's
say something like Facebook and the
people were watching screens while
eating on average gained 7 kilos in the
first semester of school so paint that
you know and you know most people eat
alone so eating in company of other
people else being mindful which eating
and not rushing through meals probably
the best tip I can give you on that the
next question comes from Dean laughter
ah does he fit
workouts of individuals with different
needs body type stages in life odd is
the encourage positive building habits
to accelerate one's progression what are
three to five best practices he
recommends for someone to adopt to for
staying fit for life well that's a lot
of questions Dean but let me answer them
one at a time
I adapt training programs based on goals
first so where do you want and based on
what you want I give you an estimate on
how fast you can do it so you know
people with full shelf at say I want to
lose 55 pounds by when in two weeks for
my nephew's Bar Mitzvah hey I don't have
holes in my hands and my feet I can't do
miracles so I always put that back into
a reality on a bench brush 400 how much
can you bench press 95 pounds well let's
take the next seven years to get there
so to increase strength for example if
you are gifted within seven years you
could triple your strength if you're not
gifted you can multiply your strength by
500
very few people do that because they
don't know either train but if you go
see a great lifting coach I can say John
Burroughs ill triple your strength in
seven years because now he knows how to
do it and I can tell you right now it
doesn't use peer-reviewed scientific
papers to decide how to train so the
sorts of things experience versus
reading the research once I know your
goals then I make it with you the
Braverman test which is a way to see
which neurotransmitters you are gifted
at producing in which one you're not at
and based on in New York transmitters
makeup I will make you train heavy a lot
of variation no variation and I teach
down my advanced program design classes
it takes three days to learn this but
neurotransmitter profile is key into the
setting what you need to do I'll do I
encourage building positive habits well
the most important thing is that you
have to look at progression not
perfection so what do you do for an
Abbott one well you know if you have an
appointed entus and you know you're
going to be charged if you don't show up
and you'll give 24 hours notice you
don't miss your dentist's appointment
but people are not treating your body
properly the most important habit is to
actually have regular training hours
according to some research and Slovakia
some better if people do better doing
early morning workouts or evening
workouts because depending at the time
they make the androgens throughout the
day so a good clinical setting damning
tip I could give you your sex drive if
you wake up under a teepee every morning
you need to take a handstand take a piss
you probably make your your androgens
very early so ship train in the morning
some people are at a greater sex drive
in the afternoon then they should train
in the afternoon so optimizing that
makes a difference also recording
everything you do compares talks about
these two experiments and all that stuff
that's great to do because
if you don't live consciously you don't
know what really works and then by
having accurate journals of what you do
you'll be able to figure out what's best
for you next question from Peter Lam or
Lana is there a way to combine strength
training and long cardio sessions I've
got two goals for three months run a
half a marathon less than two hours and
increase my benchpress from seven kilos
three sets of eight to nine kilos three
sets of eight I weigh 90 kilos and I'm
46 well peter is an N Garen proverb if
you only got one ass you can't sit on
two horses to go for three sets of eight
to seven kilos up to 90 kilos is a
realistic goal but if you do train for a
half marathon at the same time it's
going to take three to four times the
time it takes so what I suggest you pick
one goal and work on it and then once
you've accomplished a goal move on to
the next goal it's like in the movie The
Last Samurai
too many minds you really have to
concentrate on one goal of time
there's a famous Norwegian with latarian
exercise physiology professor with top
ranked at the Olympic Games in
weightlifting and E train for the
marathon for a year and then clean jerk
a pretty decent weight but you could do
the proceed listen wait because what
people don't understand is that yes
larger muscles that have your weight but
the main reason why you're strong in the
pound-for-pound basics is actually
develop the ability to recruit our
threshold motor units so
the key lesson from that bill your
strengths first and then work on your
endurance next question Jeff Garza
there's a good agency of people online
claim Europeans and protocols lack
scientific basis are you respond to
these people Thanks all right clinicians
are always ahead of the curve so for
example in February 2008 in the Journal
of flights for science research they
published a paper cluster training a
novel approach to develop maximal
strength
so remember date February 2008 I first
did cluster training when it's 14 years
old I learnt it from my coach learnt it
in 1968 when that article was published
I tried to go back and find where it
came from and apparently it was used in
1948 the some records of it that of guys
you prepare for the 48 World
Championships who are using cluster
training so if you look at it you have
60 years between guys figure out it's a
great training method versus a 2008 how
many Olympics is that if you only count
Summer Olympics you divide by 4 that's
15 Olympics if you add the Winter Games
the multiply by 2
we're up to 30 Olympics I've had plenty
of Milan pians that when I start to
coach for the Moscow Olympics we've been
doing cluster training so if I waited
for the research so from 1980 to 2008
we're looking at 28 years 28 years of ID
by 7 is 4 times 2 right so we are I
would have wasted 14 I want the games
waiting for research to happen you look
at for example Arnold's for secure
straining I'm pretty sure that he didn't
use peer-reviewed studies to develop his
physique one of the things he's credited
with is point deflection training so you
figure it out that if you overload
different points in the biomechanical
curve you create more I appreciate now
research can demonstrate it's great one
of the things I've been advocating since
1982 was to lower weight slowly to
more strength in my period and I was
recommending off in two to five seconds
lowering the first study to be published
to confirm that was published in 2016 by
Peres and his colleagues again I would
have wasted so many Olympic cycles not
doing it I've been advocating to change
positions to Inlet curls
since I started strength coaching in 78
and the paper that shows that turning
effort outward recruit smarter bicep for
Mars and if you turn your foot in where
you get more the medial hamstrings
what's published a few months ago so
again those haters you can say whatever
you want but the such thing color
observation and then you look at anybody
that's any good they will tell you also
ought not to train he says what's the
best way to train because whether I
talked to John Meadows are they've Tate
or at calm they will say after I this
didn't work so you know these people are
obsessed with results and they've tried
many things to get there and then they
after a while to figure out what works
and what doesn't so I don't really care
when they say and the other thing too is
it a lot of people say oh there's no
research on that for example leucine I
recommend much higher dosage of leucine
and my colleagues and then I've been
attacked
there's no papers and yes there's papers
but they're in French and actually those
two French papers use real training
programs lovely Studies on supplements
the program that the subjects do is not
even a workout it's more like a warm-up
but the two French studies I like on
using loosing at people do 20 sets per
body part and measure different dosage
of leucine and the highest dose are the
greatest results and they tested up at
the 30 grams so the point is they're
often there is research when they claim
there's no research you just don't know
how to look for it for example she
Chandra has 88 synonyms so if you just
google compartment and search and resuce
Chandra you'll find X amount of studies
but if you go through every synonym
you'll find more studies holy basil has
hundreds of synonyms
and you could search for the basal and
research but if you look under Tulsi the
Sanskrit name you'll find countless
numbers of papers so those people make
those claims that are not scientific
they only have one thing in common
they've never produced results and
haters will always hate and I guess it's
frustrating to them that I've got great
results and you don't have any so we
pick on that but all the training I do
is based on science and this thing also
is common sense I don't need a study
with double-blind at a full speed front
kick with a pair construction boots with
steel toes will damage your testicles if
you want to be part of the possibly
placebo group go ahead but you know this
such as the guys comment says so that's
why I never meet see me engage in
disputes or those guys because one
things one of the things my father
taught me is you have to play fair and
those guys are nitwit so I don't engage
and debate with them the next question
comes from Preston Parish I once heard
and say if you're in strength you can't
get a female client to do 12 pull-ups in
12 weeks then you're not very good and
you should quit turning plans to get
women's to do 12 pull-ups best exercise
to help with 12 fill ups very simple
answer Preston just go on YouTube and
search on your chin up performance I
give you numerous tips on how to improve
channel performance a lot of reasons why
people can't do chin-ups is they don't
know what to recruit in my upcoming
membership site I will actually give
actual programs to do that and after
demonstrate the exercise so the podcast
is not the best way to learn that but
the information will be available on my
membership site the next question is
from Morgan Brown if you only had to
pick one important factor between sleep
food and exercise which would you pick
and/or how would you prioritize them
well morgan ethic asking me for optimal
health share prioritize my liver or my
heart or my brain or made renals or my
kidney
all of those are important you'll have a
brain I'll forget not a heart forget if
you don't have a liver you know you're
live really long so you can't prioritize
so much let's say if we look at
prisoners at Club fed they can sleep as
much as they want it's a sleep restful
probably not because maybe you roommate
wants to kill you the food food is
prison foods it's not the greatest but
they do have plenty of opportunity
exercise and they have weight rooms so
in that case you could argue people can
get a good physique and if you look at
the book of jll strong by Josh Bryant
some pretty good physics we built behind
bars but then again you see that guys
will make you safe and then we'll give
you Cal your foods all these guys will
grow a lot I don't not sure taxpayers
would agree with that thing but he can't
prioritize them you can't say I'm just
going to sleep the muscle growth I'm
just going to exercise the muscle growth
I'm just going to eat the muscle growth
you need l3 next questions from Ryan
Riley cryotherapy seems to be an
interesting topic Pacific Stream nature
what are your thoughts on trying it just
for the experience meaning I don't have
any good reason to go but intrigues me
what benefits comes from it from the
average person a few years ago actually
in 2001 it was very fashionable for
proteins were sold on buying cryo suits
so the guy would train put the crab suit
on cost on in 50 grand and they claimed
it was good for recovery so this
strength coach for my rugby team said
hey should I invest into that I said
well based on the quality of your weight
room I would take around with 50 grand
buy yourself some real dumbbells and
some real equipment that is more
important to cryotherapy suit and this
is why you know I fell first first
things come first so if you go to the
choice between her therapy and a good
way don't get a good way per say okay
let's say if I've got a good rate one
would you buy the crack therapy suit I
said no because unless you want to train
yourself to be a Navy SEAL and withstand
extreme temperatures if use crowd
therapy post exercise
it will increase cortisol and it will
actually slow down your progress which
is there any papers on that I said no
but I said buy one and tell me how it
worked and then turns out that we keep
getting the same call and all those
cryotherapy suits that were bought in
2001 they're all in storage in sports
clubs they don't work it slows down its
recovery
some people argue that you could use
cryotherapy short-term to increase
healing your tissue colleagues of mine
have said yeah it's a good thing because
you get reactive hyperemia so increase
blood flow to the body parts but to be
fair I don't have enough practical
experience or read enough research on it
to validate its use but I can't really
one thing it does not increase recovery
Pro Sport Alvey actually slows it down
next question is from Andres car so beat
yo yo top things you've learned in last
two years in the last two years have
reinforced importance of measuring your
transmitters for improving program
selection so some people are driven by
variation some people do better with
many peeling manipulating workloads some
people do better by keeping the program
more constant have less variation so
keeping that in mind when I train people
I use that I've been doing that since
2001 on a regular basis but I'm more and
more convinced because I've taught the
system to students the reason why like a
chemist being one the most important
thing I've learned last two years is
that many my students once I start to
create that class started through that
and they were all representing them
record reported that they had much
faster results when they once they've
applied with system so that would be
number one number two it's more like our
vital sleep is I've always known it to
be employment last two years there's
more and more research and for example
if someone wants to increase their
testosterone naturally the single most
important factor is actually sleep and
we sleep far too less with also very
poor quality because people read them
messages before bed and look at screen
so avoiding screen time it is very
important for sleep quality and then the
next question is that what is he know
that the it's not well known amongst the
scientific world goes back to point one
I know well how to use newer
transmitters to maximize training
response however in the maths book I
wrote I use a 70% rule so you know
from last 38 years I've made it so that
it will maximize training progress
regardless of your because I am NOT
psychic and I'm not going to write you
enable drives program so people wanted a
program that would work for most of the
population and if that's what I did but
a lot of it has to do with what's the
optimal amount if I don't know you are
what's the best variation it's the best
I could do for the last 38 years
Jonathan Hyde asks for someone who's
wanting to start coaching the strength
and conditioning world would you
recommend something other than see SGS
what search would open up the most doors
again it's asked to do with ODG learn
under
I see a strength coach that is that
produce a lot of athletes consistently
over the years
no cert will do that for you and expect
to work for free
parentheses telling me that people come
to the office and say I want to train
pro athletes by the guy zero experience
so it's classic answer is don't we all
so you have to apprentice and if you're
this involved counting reps if you went
to work for me and he said I'm very keen
I would first assess how much do you
know
I would assume I would expect you sorry
to know your bisect biomechanics you
know know your basic physiology know of
floating parameters that's the homework
you need to do on yourself by yourself
before you show up and probably the
first thing you would do is just count
reps and then I would teach you to
select load why is Ben Prentice the best
strength coach in America because one
things I taught him was application of
strength program design I only Levin to
start writing programs after two years
you know so it's like wax on wax off you
got to do your basis basics before you
want to be a strength coach and there's
no cert that will do that for you
defens Frankel says were your thoughts
on your to method fasting for trying to
gain lean muscle in my opinion it's a
waste of time some people claim
fantastic gains from doing that but I've
never seen any evidence of that if you
look at the research both brain and
muscle performance are negatively
affected by intermittent fasting so I'm
not keen and that there's not a single
animal in the world that will
voluntarily fast and you'd look at
anybody big really big and really strong
what they if they lead it on fast and
you know you don't grow muscle overnight
it's good 60 of effort that matters one
of my earlier mentors was Bill star and
he will tell you and I fully agree with
him but he told me that luckily I was 17
years old was that the biggest thing the
gain strength and size is consistency
and that is
particularly true for eating food now on
internet people claim all sorts of thing
about Empyrean passing but and never
seen any visual proof of that
and then Derek met anybody said hey I'm
I'm an intermittent fasting depakote and
here are my results so in my opinion
it's a waste of time
shame quenelle what is the most
effective efficient way to increase
strength in a squat and deadlift when
aiding a plateau my website is full of
information I'll go break those plateaus
in that thing so you would have to go to
strengthen sitcom but in a nutshell you
have to very you're loading parameters
but the biggest mistake I've seen people
living plateaus it's because they've
been doing one type of squat and one
type of deadlift since Jimmy Carter was
president variation of overload in the
strength curve is probably the most
neglected factor in overcoming a plateau
so you could a little the bottom of the
strength of let's say pausing the squat
or you could use change to match the
strength curve or use bans you explosive
port it doesn't matter but probably the
best program to improve your squat build
lifting program you've never done out
again I will reinforce don't be cheap
open up your wallet and are somebody is
good and improving your squat again
books will do something reading
underneath something but I would say for
example your squat is terrible go to the
Las Vegas book an appointment John
Burroughs you look at youth it's okay
it's quite it's terrible because of this
is not in the right your program and the
amount of time you're going to waste on
your net trying to find the solution
will be offset by investing money your
deadlift sucks find that comb go see him
there's a lot of good coaches out there
or your bench press is terrible
go see Josh Bryant is the expert
improving your bench press but
face-to-face consultation is the
surefire way to improve the lift the
next verse is from here on down what has
he been a proponent of in the past they
no longer believes perhaps a scientific
study updates actually probably what
I've had I've changed over the years is
that I used to use very short cycles
like two weeks and then call you mind
convinced me to go to three week cycles
and from experience I may do only five
days cycles so I realized that you know
basically strength training is like
learning a foreign language so you need
to change it stimulus if you repeat the
same words over and over again in the
same order and I got a strong set a good
example I give is let's say if you're
learning English and I show you in
writing didi didi really say it you have
no idea because there's no intonation of
the meaning of the sentence but if I say
did he really say it it implies is it
him or not or did he really say it you
get the drift so anywhere I put the
emphasis on the word
the meaning of the sentence will be
different the same with strength
training I see as time went by I
realized that you need to put the
emphasis on something different and one
of the things that I find works for
everybody is much shorter training
cycles I don't like to go more than two
weeks or four workouts being repeated
the next question is from Jason Cohen
what new insight CD he gained training
women's wrestlers Helena release and
they'll end up your score before the
Olympic Games in Rio well thanks for the
question Jason two years ago I announced
on Facebook that was going to start
working with wrestlers and it was
amazing the amount of hate poche I got
which way would say some like you don't
know anything about wrestling you know
what you're going to make them do trains
I said you know hey there's going to be
a turd so I used that as a good
motivation to show that I could train
wrestlers and helmet rule is
came in first when I look at gold first
American wrestler to do so in history
and she'd be the girl that only lost
twice in 20 years
or 16 years boh-chan losses ago fight in
12 years and
Helen as you can see the videos on
YouTube mangle dorky over powder and
then when I was looking for the fight
online I kept getting text messages or
whatsapp messages from my students
telling me congratulations and they were
that stage miss like ensuing and all
they talked about was our she dominated
everybody with strength so it's part
there was a first one of the best public
display every rat about people could
relate the effect of strength training
on allens win and yell and hell didn't
do so bad she came in fifth and since
then I get asked every day to work with
more wrestlers of different countries
but what did I learn when I first
started working for the two athletes
asked and actually thing what are your
norms for strength training and there
was none so I've done norms for strength
training for sports all my life so it's
okay let's look at that and again I
didn't have a double-blind studies but I
figured out if he gets throwing at
chin-ups that should help you would take
down snapping the neck reversals and so
on because the lats and the elbow
flexors are prime movers in those
movements so I've only trained for the
World Championships Helen for three
times six weeks and once you start with
me in January she do 0 chin-ups and she
did to superior chance with 27 kilos 5
days before she left for the World
Championships which she won for Rio
I trained there six weeks on Christmas
six weeks in the spring so the toll of
strength training was about 12 weeks in
preparation for real and she managed you
to pull ups on the Rings with the 30
kilos the day before she flew out to Rio
and chilling up a goal in every credits
strength I've been one of the major
factors with why she want it's not the
only factor I mean this woman doesn't
have mindset she has soul set she's very
driven very smart she learned Japanese
so she could understand what the culture
is telling rope on between stop
right so the thing is is that what I
learned is that there's some basic lifts
that do transfer to wrestling the most
important ones are squats and deadlifts
and Chin's so if you drive those lifts
up providing everything's equal you
should have transferred into the
wrestling mat number two is that I was
amazed at the
misconceptions they're still surrounding
wrestling so people would laugh at her
because she lifted weight but once you
won the World Championships and lifting
weights very close to competition you
will say you should do that you're gonna
be too heavy after cut weight but I've
got a few tricks up my sleeve ah now we
got strong and not put on any weight and
then for the world champ if I start for
the only games she decided to keep
training up to the competition which in
wrestling is avoided like the plague the
one she won the world champion you would
see on Instagram all our competitors
taking videos of themself training but
the methods they're using Laurentis
here's quite funny I mean it was a cure
for depression - look at those do that
DVDs the end videos and for example when
she beat the Swedish girl you know again
in Sweden they said you know she's far
superior by strength so the insides are
one squat deadlift and chins increments
will improve transfer on the mat number
two you need this value in training
close to the competition and number
three based on the response I'm getting
now people are valuing how much strength
training can do for combative sport next
question from Ryan the sink
what's this process in learning new
languages again I think it's exposure so
everywhere I go I make it a habit to
learn at least how to say hello goodbye
thank you no problem and I learn basic
sentences because if you're the
restaurant you know the last year you
want bottle of water you don't tap water
you want the water with bubbles no
bubbles which I coffee so they go let's
see the Slovakia I'll go on being
translator write down these sandwiches I
have a local person teaching the correct
pronunciation and let's see if I'm
writing a cab I'll look at ads and try
to guess what they are so I'll write
them down go back go on being translate
write down with the ad said
and I pick it up but the more languages
you learned easier it is and I was in
Prag with the owners of Wolf cake and
having dinner and one of the tricks that
L see with Ling languages a pay
attention when my friends are speaking
and I try to slow down internally the
conversation and then so now I say okay
this word must mean this so remember the
guy was ordering a drink I said them
that must be orange juice the guy with a
surprise it picked up because the word
was not at all similar to what we have
in our language so it's learning
languages like strength training as well
I mean it's repeated exposure so I found
that the Pimsleur method is probably the
best method to learn hiring somebody to
teach you and again don't be cheap
sometimes people did for free they'll do
as a trade but in my field how many
times I say stick your chest out put
your elbows under the bar lift your chin
so all these key sentences I write them
down being transit them verify with a
local if it's it be sometimes being
translated isn't the good javathread but
they do a pretty good job most of the
time and I say teach real sandwiches and
because I keep repeating them throughout
the workout they sink in but now I know
the word the verb strengthen I know
backhand or a bunch of work and that
another thing I do is I try to read the
menu and understand what it means and I
was in Montenegro last summer and they
had sometimes English and Serbian menu
so I learned quickly I would say chicken
beef and whatever then I went on the
coast and had the choice between Russian
and Serbian and Cyrillic but I've taken
Russian before Samuel to read Cyrillic
and then so I would read the Serbian
menu and I knew all to order ribeye and
all that stuff because I had memorized
myself in the capital but Goleta with
the menu and even my hosts were
surprised how quickly
pick up stuff so it's just a matter of
having an open mind and be keen I mean I
like learning foreign language used to
have many employees and the way you can
bother did agree on see thank you and
please and I think that's quite rude the
least you could do is let me say thank
you and welcome when you go to foreign
country the next question is from Kyle
Kulina what's your favorite book I
probably would say the one thing is my
favorite book because it teaches you
what to focus on and what's most
important and I change it from you is
the the 4-hour workweek and noting that
the kiss Kim's ass but I think that the
concepts in your book were very
important to master next question is
from Joshua bathily bazi what is Charles
poliquin's one thing the one thing is to
finish my membership site have been
working over the last three years it
took me far longer than what I thought
I've learned quite a bit during that
process it's as simple as people think
but I'm very proud of being able to open
it in January the thing with the
membership website is that there's a lot
of confusion on the market I can't teach
seminars 365 days a year so I kind of
listened to my friend John Berardi I
decide to make guidelines what I'm
willing to do and what I'm not willing
to do I'm willing to educate a lot of
people but I can't travel so much and
then my information is valuable so I
create a membership site and I've had
quite a few colleagues look at it and
the interesting comment I've had is I
have too much information so for example
we filmed 188 forms a squat I was going
to leave all the squats there they don't
know just show five new ones a month
because people get overwhelmed any
stopped going and my goal is to make it
the best website for strength training
nutrition on the web I'm very confident
in doing so the people who have seen the
content or blown away because there's
things that I will teach in there
through videos that you can only get in
my classes I mean it's really hard to
write about these things a lot of times
it's demonstration is key in learning
let's go
some Chaz Christian and Sonali what is
your crowning achievement I'm not sure
if you're asking me why is it I'm most
proud of what I'm most proud of as not a
cure dia I do something I don't think
it's the end of the world like you know
last summer at two athletes when metals
have been epic won and triple jump we're
in wrestling that's great but eight
minutes later I'm looking at my next
goal so I don't believe in crowning
achievement a crowning achievement is
what people talk about when you're dead
I intend to be on this planet for far
longer so I don't have a crowning
achievement everything I do is part of a
pathway otherwise your life is not worth
living so that is all thank you for
listening on my website we'll have
strings and sitcom flash Tim Ferriss
slash resources for the addresses where
to buy some of the products or books
have mentioned and for you if you are
interested in buying the ultimate mask
program you will be strengthened see /
Tim Ferriss / mask and you'll be able to
have access to thank you for listening
and best of luck in all of your training
endeavors thank you hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday the vent
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour work week
calm
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by trunk
club there are two types of men out
there you know who you are guys who love
shopping for clothes but are short on
time category a and those of you who
hate it
category B I am in the latter category
my fashion sense is also probably
somewhere between homeless and confused
with a dash of lazy added in either way
you can take heart and I've used trunk
club now and have found some of my
favorite pieces of clothing that make me
look a lot better than I'll be able to
handle on my own and there are many
reasons for that but you can get
clothing that fits perfectly and looks
amazing without ever stepping into a
store again thanks to trunk club and
they make it very very easy and the
clothing is handpicked by a personal
stylist your own personal stylist all
you have to do is go to trunk club comm
forward slash Tim type in your
measurements share your likes and
dislikes they'll pick your clothes from
more than 80 top brands and ship them
right to your door you keep what you
like you send back what you don't if you
don't like any of it send it all back it
doesn't matter and trunk club is not a
subscription service this is what
appealed to me among many other things I
didn't want to constantly be getting
dinged by things or have to deal with
the headache of constantly getting boxes
it's not a subscription service shipping
is always free then you have five days
to try on the clothes so a couple points
here number one get started today go to
trunk club comm forward slash Tim try it
out you get premium clothes expert
advice no work no risk that is a winning
combo and I have found some of my
favorite espadrilles shoes from them
bright green I do like the color green
and they actually work I've had so many
compliments on these shoes and more
people asking where I got them than any
other pair of shoes I've ever had and
more shirts I kept end up keeping about
I would say three quarters in my box
which I did not expect to do so go to
trunk club comm forward slash Tim and
check it out dozens maybe even hundreds
of you have asked me what shirts are you
wearing on YouTube videos for very
specific set of shirts and they are from
Rowan apparel RH o-n-e and I'm packing
for a trip for seven to ten days and I
would say half of what I'm going to pack
is from run these are the most
comfortable shirts and they have much
more than shirts that I have ever worn
at least for active wear for getting out
and about and you can even sneak them in
to say a business casual or a dinner if
you want if you're a Long Island kid
like me they have minimal branding you
don't feel like you are walking around
with some type of billboard on your
chest anti-odor technology because I am
a smelly bastard and I can somewhat end
up smelling like a musk ox halfway
through the day they pure melted down
silver in their fabrics and I love these
shirts I love their pants I love the
shorts and I've been wearing them pretty
much every day for the last few weeks at
least one item from them so you should
check it out this stuff is not cheap
because it is made from premium
materials and if you want the best you
got to pay for the best and that's just
the way it is but there's no risk in
trying them out they provide free
shipping and a 100 day return policy
that is plenty of time to feel them out
so check it out at rowan dot-com forward
slash Tim that's Rho n e.com forward
slash Tim you can get 15% off which is
exclusive for listeners of this podcast
you're welcome
using the code Tim you gotta use the
code folks and at that URL wrong comport
slash Tim you will also see the shirt
that I would suggest maybe starting with
it is the scout crew neck shirt I like
the red I like the black I'm wearing the
red right now as I record this and that
is all for this sponsor announcement so
check it out Rowan calm forward-slash
tip
you